Wenn es nicht stimmt, dass ein menschlicher Akteur,
wenn er vor die Wahl zwischen
miteinander unvereinbaren Handlungen gestellt wird,
zumindest manchmal in der Lage und in der Lage ist
, jede von ihnen auszuführen, dann sind die schlechten
Folgen seiner Wahl niemals seine
eigene Schuld, das heißt, er ist es dann nie
Schuld daran ist das Schuldproblem.
In seinem Buch Nachdenken über
Willensfreiheit verbindet Peter van Inwagen zwei
plausible Thesen über das, was wir gemeinhin
Willensfreiheit nennen.
Die erste plausible These ist, dass wir
menschlichen Akteuren, wenn wir vor die Wahl
zwischen miteinander unvereinbaren Handlungen gestellt
werden, nichts im Wege steht  zumindest in einigen Fällen in der Lage und in der
Lage ist, jede von ihnen auszuführen, und die
zweite plausible Ansicht ist, dass, wenn
die Folgen einer Handlung
einem Agenten zugeschrieben werden sollen, der sich entschieden hat
, diese Handlung auszuführen, es eine
Kollegialgelegenheit geben muss,
in der dieser Agent tätig ist
fähig und in der Lage war, jede der Handlungen auszuführen,
zwischen denen er sich zu
entscheiden versuchte, ist die erste These dann
nicht nur plausibel wahr, sondern simpel  Natürlich
ist es meine feste Überzeugung, dass es
richtig ist, eine solche Verbindung
zwischen diesen beiden Thesen anzunehmen, aber durch die
Berufung auf zusätzliche Thesen wird eine Invasion
beschrieben, die eine dialektische oder
sogar dilemmaartige Situation beschreibt, die
in der zeitgenössischen Debatte besondere Aufmerksamkeit erhalten hat,
sind diese zusätzlichen Thesen  Die ersten
beiden Thesen über die Begriffe
Determinismus und Indeterminismus, wobei
Determinismus die Negation des
Determinismus ist und beide einen ausschließlichen
Widerspruch bilden.
Dies ist der dritte Satz
ist die These, dass
die Vergangenheit und die Naturgesetze
nicht die eindeutige Zukunft bestimmen,
diese zusätzlichen Visa unsere zweite
These bezüglich dieser beiden
berühmten Argumente, wonach die
erste These, dass wir zu bestimmten
Gelegenheiten in der Lage und in der Lage sind,
jede der Handlungen auszuführen  kann weder wahr sein,
wenn Determinismus der Fall ist, noch wahr sein,
wenn i  Beim Determinismus, also der Negation
des Determinismus, handelt es sich jedoch um einen
Satz, der mit beiden
Gliedern eines ausschließlichen Widerspruchs
unvereinbar wahr ist und daher die
beiden berühmten und vieldiskutierten
Argumente, die Teil einer Invarianz der
vorgenannten Thesen sind, zum einen sind
Andererseits, wie er zuvor sagte, das sogenannte
Konsequenz-Argument, wonach,
wenn Determinismus zu meinen Handlungen gehört,
immer logische Folgen
unvermeidlicher Bedingungen in der fernen Vergangenheit
zusammen mit ebenso unvermeidlichen
Naturgesetzen sind, so dass das, was ich entscheide, nicht
frei, sondern auch bewohnbar und bewohnbar ist  das so
genannte verstandsargument,
wonach, wenn meine
entscheidung, die wir bestimmen, unbestimmt wäre,
mein handeln nicht das ergebnis einer
kontrollierten und freien entscheidung wäre, dass es sich um eine rein
zufällige entscheidung handelt, ist
das dilemma daher die folgende
unsere hauptthese, dies ist eine über unsere
Die kontrollierte Fähigkeit, zwischen
mindestens zwei miteinander unvereinbaren
Aktionen zu wählen, muss falsch sein, wenn keine der beiden  o
Argumente sind aus plausiblen Gründen widerlegbar.
Im Folgenden werde ich nicht
direkt eines der
unbeantwortbaren Argumente der Spaßinvarianz angreifen, das Konsequenzargument,
sondern das Gedankenargument. Stattdessen werde ich
mich
auf die Unterscheidung zwischen
Determinismus und Indeterminismus konzentrieren
Frage, ob es Formen von
Determinismus und Indeterminismus gibt, die möglicherweise
nicht streng widersprüchlich sind, denn wenn
es Formen von Determinismus und
Indeterminismus gibt, die möglicherweise nicht streng
widersprüchlich sind, folgt daraus, dass die These,
selbst wenn sie sowohl mit dem Determinismus unvereinbar zu sein scheint, als auch der
Indeterminismus
selbst sehr wohl sein könnte  wahr, lassen Sie mich
eine seiner Invarianzbemerkungen über seine
Unterscheidung zwischen Determinismus und
Indeterminismus als Ausgangspunkt verwenden, und
es gibt dieses Zitat, es gibt scheinbar
unbeantwortbare Argumente, die zeigen,
dass These eins mit Determinismus unvereinbar ist.
Ich spiele natürlich auf die
verschiedenen Versionen des Konsequenzarguments an
wie es ist  in der Branche bekannt und
es gibt scheinbar unbeantwortbare
Argumente, die zeigen, dass These
eins mit dem Determinismus unvereinbar ist.
Dieser Teil erfordert ein wenig Arbeit, da der
Determinismus nicht impliziert, dass
die Handlungen einer bestimmten Person unbestimmt sind, die
Arbeit kann am Ende des Zitats lustig im Wagen erledigt werden
diese kleine Zusatzarbeit für den
Fall des Indeterminismus bereits mehrfach geleistet hat
, also eine Form des
Indeterminismus beschrieben hat, die sich auf die Handlungsentscheidung einer
bestimmten Person zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt bezieht, werde ich mich
nun einer dieser Beschreibungen zuwenden
Dass in dem Artikel ein vielversprechendes
Argument zu finden ist, lässt mich in dieser Sammlung bereits
erwähntes Nachdenken über die freie Welt
vorschlagen, aber lassen Sie mich zunächst vorschlagen, Determinismus zu nennen
, wie er auf die Handlungshandlungen einer bestimmten Person angewendet wird, die
in der ISM persönlich lokalisiert ist,
und Determinismus zu nennen,
der nicht bestimmt ist  Angewandt auf eine Person durch
zusätzliche Arbeit allgemeiner Determinismus ist meine
Leitfrage, ob überhaupt
diese Abschreckung gewährt wird  Minimismus und Indeterminismus, wie
oben zitiert, sind widersprüchlich Es gibt
eine Form des allgemeinen Determinismus, die
dem persönlich lokalisierten Determinismus nicht widerspricht
, wie er von einer
Umgebung im Allgemeinen beschrieben wird. Mein Ziel ist es,
eine Form des Determinismus zu finden, die schwach
genug ist, um einen persönlich lokalisierten nicht auszuschließen
Determinismus und das
daher schwach genug ist, um dem Argument der unbeantwortbaren Konsequenz zu entgehen, das
aber andererseits stark genug ist
, um dem Gedankenargument in gewisser Weise zu entkommen
, wonach es scheint, dass im
Fall
einer Person im Determinismus die Entscheidungen einer Person lokalisiert sein müssen
Lassen Sie mich nun
auf die kleine Arbeit eingehen, die Fan
in Wagon bereits geleistet hat,
wodurch der Determinismus auf
die Handlungen einer bestimmten Person in einer bestimmten
Situation der Wahl anwendbar wird, und dies
wird am Anfang von beschrieben  Es ist ein
vielversprechendes Argument, das ich zitiere, lassen Sie uns sagen,
dass es von einem bestimmten Moment zu einem bestimmten
Moment von einem abhängt, ob man etwas tun
oder sein wird  wenn man dann vor die
wahl gestellt wird zwischen hilfe und b
zu tun und man dann a tun kann und dann
b kann, dann geht nach
diesem ersten satz eines erfolgsversprechenden
arguments das fan-in-wagging von zwei
dingen in bezug auf aus  Bei einer bevorstehenden
Entscheidung geht er zunächst davon aus, dass es
allein Sache des menschlichen Agenten ist, welche Handlung
er ausführen wird, bis zu einem
Bruder, der eine tun wird, oder um an zweiter Stelle zu stehen,
geht er davon aus, dass der menschliche Agent in der Lage und in der
Lage ist, jede der Aktionen auszuführen
unvereinbare handlungen fähigkeit im
entsprechenden sinne, jede von ihnen auszuführen die
schwierigkeit, die fan-in-waggon weiter
beschreibt, liegt in der tatsache, dass seiner meinung
nach das erste element, das
bedeutet, ob man zu a oder b will,
persönlich lokalisiert sein muss  im
determinismus eine These von in wagenrufen
im kompatibilismus und ich zitiere im
kompatibilismus im sinne von fremden
ländern wenn man in einem bestimmten moment
vor der wahl steht, a oder
b zu tun, dann liegt es an einem selbst, ob man
es tut  ein oder sein nur dann
unbestimmt ist, ob man ein oder
sein wird und notwendigerweise so Ende des Zitats
aber und die gleiche Person in Johnson
tut mir leid, aber ein und dieselbe
Person, die
laut Fan in der DTM tatsächlich in Determinismus lokalisiert ist
MA im Bestimmungsprinzip scheint
das zweite Element der Entscheidungskompetenz auszuschließen, das
in der Lage und in der
Lage ist, beide Handlungen auszuführen,
zwischen denen man sich entscheiden muss. Ich zitiere
dieses neue Unbestimmtheits-
Unfähigkeitsprinzip, wobei t2 ein zukünftiger
Moment und t1 ein zukünftiger Moment früher
als ist  t2 f1 steht nun vor der Wahl
zwischen a bei t2 und B bei t2 zu tun,
und wenn bei T 1 unbestimmt sein wird,
ob man bei t2 a oder bei t2 B tun wird,
und wenn dies dann unbestimmt wäre,
was auch immer ein Geist tut
zwischen jetzt und t1 dann ist man
jetzt nicht in der lage a bei t2 und man kann
jetzt nicht in t b zweihändig
laut fan lädt eine
vermeintlich freie entscheidungskompetenz ein und
rechtfertigt schuld impos  Es sind
unvereinbare Anforderungen und
daher, wie der Artikel zu demonstrieren versucht,
unmöglich, bevor ein menschlicher
Akteur entscheidet, was zu tun ist, muss
unbestimmt sein, was er tun wird, wenn
seine Entscheidung zwischen miteinander
unvereinbaren Handlungen
nur bei ihm liegen soll, er es aber nicht kann
im relevanten sinne fähig und in der lage sein, die
betreffenden handlungen auszuführen, bevor
er entscheidet, wenn es zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht feststeht, was zu tun ist, was
dann für uns zu tun ist, überlegen wir uns
zunächst, was nach van inwagen
dazu erforderlich ist  Wahrheit des persönlich
im Determinismus lokalisierten Zitats
lassen Sie uns sagen, dass es zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt unbestimmt ist, ob man etwas
tun oder sein wird, wenn es eine mögliche Welt gibt,
in der die Naturgesetze dieselben sind
wie die der tatsächlichen Welt und  deren
momentaner Zustand mit einem
momentanen Zustand der wirklichen Welt identisch ist
und in dem man a tun wird,
und ungefähr die gleichen zwei
Bedingungen erfüllen, in denen man B tun wird
es gibt drei Dinge, die wir brauchen, um
persönlich zu lokalisieren D Bestimmung
es muss eine tatsächliche Welt geben, in der
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt eine Entscheidung
ansteht nennen wir diese Welt zeitliche Wahlwelt
oder T Seaboard weiter müssen
es mindestens zwei mögliche Welten sein
mit einer TC-Welt bis dahin kongruent sind
und die sich von diesem Zeitpunkt an voneinander unterscheiden,
ohne
ihrer eigenen Vergangenheit zu widersprechen, gleichzeitig mit der TC-
Welt nenne ich sie die mögliche A-Welt
und die mögliche P-Welt und schließlich in
diesen beiden möglichen Welten  es
müssen Naturgesetze sein, die
in der A-Welt und in der B-Welt gleich sind und
die zudem mit den
Naturgesetzen der TC-Welt übereinstimmen.
Betrachten wir zunächst die mindestens zwei möglichen
Welten mit gleicher Vergangenheit
nach van
inwagen davon auszugehen ist, dass die TC-welt angesichts der oben genannten
bedingungen für einen persönlich lokalisierten determinismus einen personal lokalisierten
determinismus hat  o
mit einer möglichen Welt identisch sein, aber
zu einem Zeitpunkt vor der Entscheidung
unbestimmt im Sinne einer
Invarianzdefinition davon ist,
mit welcher dieser möglichen Welten
die TK-Welt identisch ist, hängt für gegebene
persönlich lokalisierte im Determinismus
davon ab  davon, wie der menschliche Agent
entscheiden wird, ob er entscheidet,
Aktion a auszuführen, die TC-Welt identisch mit
der möglichen a-Welt ist, wenn er sich entscheidet
, Aktion B auszuführen, die TC-Welt
identisch mit der möglichen B-Welt
ist, ist daher unbestimmt, ob der
TC  Welt ist die mögliche a-Welt oder die
mögliche B-Welt, aber
ist es zumindest nicht unbestimmt, dass die
TC-Welt entweder die mögliche a-Welt
oder die mögliche be-Welt ist, das heißt, ist es
wahr, dass die TC-Welt die mögliche B-
Welt ist, wenn sie es ist?  nicht die mögliche heyyou-
Welt und dass es die mögliche a-
Welt ist, wenn es nicht die mögliche B-Welt
ist, scheint mir, dass dies nicht
mindestens so lange persönlich
im Determinismus lokalisiert ist wie des  cripted by fan
invariant gilt, denn nach heutigem Stand der Dinge
in der TC-Welt
schließt nichts aus, dass die TC-Welt die
mögliche a-Welt ist, ferner
mögliche B-Welt ist, folglich
schließt nichts aus, dass sie nicht die mögliche a-
Welt ist  und ebenso schließt nichts aus, dass
es sich nicht um die mögliche B-Welt handelt, sondern
die TC-Welt könnte aus heutiger Sicht
vor der Entscheidung weder die mögliche
a-Welt noch die mögliche B-Welt sein,
sondern eine andere mögliche Welt,
je nachdem, wie jemand in a entscheiden würde
Situation von persönlich lokalisiertem
Determinismus Tatsächlich scheint van Inwagen
in einer Fußnote zuzugeben, dass, wenn ein
Agent namens Sally versucht,
in einer Situation von persönlich
lokalisiertem Determinismus zu entscheiden, es viel mehr Möglichkeiten geben könnte
als nur die
Möglichkeiten, die der Agent
eingeht  Bei seiner Entscheidung dürften daher
viel mehr mögliche Worte
mit der Vergangenheit der TC-Welt vereinbar sein als
nur das a wo  rld und sich langweilen,
folgt daraus, dass selbst nachdem ein a ein Akteur
einen der
alternativen Handlungsgründe a oder B
im Laufe der Beratung ausgeschlossen hätte,
noch immer eine
Unbestimmtheit bezüglich einer ganzen Reihe
alternativer Handlungsgründe bestehen könnte
dürfen jedoch davon ausgehen, dass es einen Unterschied für Sallys Entscheidung macht, wenn es
darum geht, dass der
persönlich im Determinismus zwischen a und B verortete
Fokus stärker auf
nicht ausgeschlossenen alternativen
Handlungsursachen liegt als auf ausgeschlossenen alternativen Handlungsursachen.
ob sie
allen in Frage kommenden Möglichkeiten
nur die Möglichkeit
, Ärztin zu werden, gegenüberstellt oder ob
sie allen Möglichkeiten gegenüberstellt,
zwischen denen sie schwankte, bevor sie schließlich
eine von ihnen ausschließt, wenn es
legitim ist, etwas in dieser Richtung anzunehmen,
ohne den Bedingungen zu widersprechen
des persönlich lokalisierten
Determinismus impliziert das Ausschließen
alternativer Ursachen  Handlungsoptionen
nach bestimmten Prinzipien verengen
den Spielraum der verbleibenden Optionen diese
verbleibenden Optionen sind dann nach
diesen Prinzipien trotz einer persönlichen
lokalen Unbestimmtheit der Wahl insgesamt
näher an der Wahl des Akteurs als
andere Optionen, die ausgeblendet, also
ausgeschlossen wurden  die mögliche Welt, die
gemäß dem persönlich im Determinismus lokalisierten Menschen
mit
der TC-Welt kompatibel sein müsste, könnte
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt in der tatsächlichen Welt eine unterschiedliche Abnahme der Nähe zu einem Agenten haben,
ohne dabei
den Bedingungen des
im Determinismus persönlich lokalisierten
David zu widersprechen  Lewis hat diesen
Unterschied der Nähe oder Nähe
zwischen möglichen Rollen bekanntlich als Grad oder
Grad der Ähnlichkeit zwischen möglichen
Welten beschrieben und versucht, ihn
gegen den Vorwurf der Schiefe in seinen
Kontrafaktualen zu verteidigen, indem er auf diesem Konzept der
Ähnlichkeitsgrade aufbaut, das er seinerseits entwickelt hat  ein
Konzept der vergleichenden
Möglichkeit  Im Folgenden fühle ich mich
von diesem Konzept von Lewis inspiriert,
ohne die Gelegenheit zu haben
, es zu diesem Zeitpunkt weiter zu diskutieren, aber
es scheint offensichtlich zu sein, wenn dieses Konzept
im Hinterkopf behalten wird, dass es nicht so ist, dass die
zwei oder mehr möglichen Welten sein
müssen  Mögliche Fortsetzungen einer Entscheidung
zwischen alternativen Handlungsursachen in
der TK-Welt nach Van in verschiedenen
Bedingungen müssen hierfür im
Determinismus gleichermaßen mögliche Welten in
Bezug auf die Lokalität von persönlich
lokalisiert sein, das heißt in
Bezug auf die Person und und die  Zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem sie vor eine Wahl gestellt
wird, könnten sie stattdessen unterschiedliche
Grade an Möglichkeiten und daher
unterschiedliche Grade an Nähe oder
Neuheit in Bezug auf ihre Verbindung
zur ttcc-Welt haben, wie die vorstehende
Argumentation jemandem gezeigt hat, der
vor der Wahl zwischen expliziten
Alternativen steht  Ursachen von Handlungen in einer
Situation von persönlich lokalisiertem
Determinismus könnten durchaus eine ganze
Reihe von d  unterschiedliche und miteinander
unvereinbare Klagegründe, so dass es,
selbst wenn sie persönlich in
Determinatoren in Löchern lokalisiert ist, an ihr liegt,
welche von ihnen sie verfolgen wird, und
dies, selbst nachdem sie
eine der alternativen Klagegründe zwischen ihnen ausgeschlossen
hat  Tatsache, dass ein menschlicher
Akteur im Kern die Tatsache, dass ein menschlicher
Akteur bei der Entscheidungsfindung
nur eine von mehreren
Möglichkeiten ausschließt, impliziert nicht, dass er
auch entschieden hat, was er tun
wird, sondern dass er sich zusätzlich entscheiden muss
für eine bestimmte Handlung mit der
Bandbreite der verbleibenden Möglichkeit möglicher
Handlungen
Ich möchte jedoch festhalten, dass
je nachdem, welcher Ausschluss
durchgeführt wurde, die Bandbreite der
möglichen Handlungen
stärker auf die verbleibende
Möglichkeit a oder stärker auf
die verbleibende Möglichkeit B konzentriert sein kann  ohne
damit den Bedingungen
der ursprünglich angenommenen,
im Determinismus lokalisierten Person
zu widersprechen, wenn man zugibt, dass es sich um einen Menschen handelt  der Akteur
vor eine Wahl gestellt wird in einer Situation
persönlich lokalisierter im Determinismus
einige aller
in Frage kommenden alternativen Handlungsursachen könnten der Wahl des Akteurs näher sein als
andere
dieser alternativen Handlungsursachen,
ohne dass dadurch der
Bedingung der Bedingung widersprochen wird  Bei dieser Form
des Determinismus muss dann auch
zugegeben werden, dass nur eine dieser
alternativen Handlungsursachen
nach bestimmten Prinzipien
der Wahl des Handelnden näher sein könnte als
jede andere dieser
alternativen Handlungsmöglichkeiten und dies abhängig davon, welche
Ausschlüsse diskutiert wurden  Agenten ausführt können
wir sagen, dass ein solcher
Klagegrund nach etwa voreiligen
zwei rationalen Entscheidungsprinzipien
der höchstmögliche Klagegrund für einen
bestimmten Agenten ist, also hatte ich einen Teil über Thomas von
Aquin, den ich aus Zeitgründen überspringen werde,
der ähnlich ist  konstruiert nach dem
Vorschlag und der Invarianz und ich komme
zu meinen Schlussfolgerungen dazu, das bringt mich
zum seco  nd Bedingung des persönlich
lokalisierten Determinismus nach
Fan-Inversion, nämlich um die Frage,
ob es aus meiner Sicht folgerichtig ist
, wenn genau eine Welt unter vielen
möglichen Fortsetzungen der TC-
Welt die nach
rationalen Prinzipien möglichst mögliche für eine Person ist, die
hat  eine Entscheidung zu treffen, dass mindestens
zwei der möglichen Welten, die mögliche
Fortsetzungen einer Entscheidung sind,
die in einer Situation des persönlich
lokalisierten Determinismus in der TC-Welt getroffen wurde,
die A-Welt und die B-Welt, dieselben Naturgesetze haben können
wie die  TC-Vorstand Ich denke, dass diese
Forderung auch erfüllt werden kann,
wenn verneint wird, dass ein vergangener Weltzustand
zusammen mit einem Zusammenwirken aller
Naturgesetze und Taser jedem anderen Weltzustand,
wie wir ihn zu
Beginn dieser These gesehen haben, gleichwertig ist
zur These des nomologischen Determinismus im
Sinne von Spaß bei Wagner die These, dass
alles, was geschieht,
ausschließlich aus einem willkürlichen Zustand des Geschehens folgt
Vergangenheit ausschließlich zusammen mit den
Naturgesetzen, obwohl meiner Meinung nach nichts
, was jemals passiert, ein Widerspruch zu
den Naturgesetzen ist oder, wie man sagen könnte,
gegen ein Naturgesetz verstößt, folgt es nicht
, wenn man einen vergangenen Zustand annimmt
, der allein durch a impliziert wird  Naturgesetz
statt dessen könnte es ausnahmslos andere Regeln oder
zwei andere Verallgemeinerungen geben,
nach denen etwas
in der Welt geschieht oder geschieht, andere
Prinzipien, das heißt, die nicht
Naturgesetze sind,
die im Determinismus, wie ihn Fan-in Veck beschreibt, persönlich lokalisiert sind
eine Kontrollentscheidung
muss zu einem Zeitpunkt vor dieser
Entscheidung nur in Bezug auf Tatsachen
der Vergangenheit und Naturgesetze der TC-
Welt bestimmt werden, dies ist offensichtlich im Einklang mit
einem allgemeinen Determinismus und Arica-Sinn,
nach dem diese Entscheidung
in Bezug bestimmt wird  zu allen relevanten
Prinzipien des zukünftigen Entscheidungsfindungsfortschritts
müssen diese Prinzipien jedoch
weder Tatsachen der Vergangenheit
noch Naturgesetze oder ne sein  Obwohl sie für
den
Entscheidungsträger
unvermeidlich sind, ist es für mich nicht unvermeidlich, dass ich
etwas nach bestimmten Prinzipien als gut oder richtig
ansehe, was
nach anderen Prinzipien
als schlecht oder
falsch angesehen wird, der allgemeine logische Determinismus
, den ich  Möglichst vorbringen möchte, ist
die These, dass die Zukunft
von allen Prinzipien bestimmt wird, die ausgehend von einem
bestimmten vergangenen Zustand der Welt
im Verlauf
der Weltgeschichte eine Rolle spielen, meiner Ansicht nach die Prinzipien,
die in der These eine Rolle spielen  eines solchen
allgemeinen oder logischen Determinismus müssen
keine Naturgesetze sein, zwei Verallgemeinerungen
, die keine Naturgesetze sind, könnten
sich zwischen Welten mit derselben Vergangenheit
und denselben Naturgesetzen wie die TC-
Welt unterscheiden, und es könnte genau eine
dieser Welten geben  wobei diese beiden
Verallgemeinerungen alle Dinge sind, die
als maximal maximal rational
und günstig für alle Menschen und andere
rationale Wesen angesehen werden, die
Entscheidungen treffen müssen  und den Thesen
des Verschuldensproblems nach
etwa Lebensbedürfnissen entsprechen, wäre eine solche mögliche
Welt nicht nur die beste aller
möglichen Welten, sondern auch identisch mit
der tatsächlichen Welt, in der ein rationaler
Determinismus
mit der Verschuldung von Personen konsequent denkbar ist
Treffen Sie rationale Entscheidungen zumindest
gemäß Light it Sir.
Es scheint daher, dass die
Bedingungen im Determinismus persönlich lokalisiert sind,
da das Fan-In-Arbeiten
mit einem schwachen Determinismus kombiniert werden kann,
der rationale Entscheidungsprinzipien
oder zwei andere Verallgemeinerungen umfasst,
die uns überlassen sind  denn diese rationalen Prinzipien
könnten mit den gleichen
Naturgesetzen vereinbar sein, unabhängig davon, welche
Handlungsalternative verfolgt wird,
so scheint es mir, dass wir allgemein behaupten können,
ohne uns selbst zu widersprechen,
dass zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt t1 in der DC-
Welt
den Determinismus persönlich lokalisiert hat
hält und es gibt mehr
als alternative Klagegründe, die
schlagen  s mehr als eine mögliche
Fortsetzung der Gegenwart, die
alle dem entscheidungsbereiten Akteur
überlassen sind, und dies, obwohl
nur eine dieser alternativen
Handlungsursachen für die
betreffende Person nach
rationalen Entscheidungsprinzipien die am ehesten mögliche ist  und dass ferner
eine vernünftige Person
aufgrund einer Beratung oder eines
Conciliums nach rationalen
Prinzipien, das nach t1 beginnt, in der Lage und in der Lage sein könnte,
den bequemsten Klagegrund zu bestimmen, der
der Klagegrund ist, der
nach einem solchen Concilium
am meisten erscheint  ratsam, wenn es
legitim ist, die These aufrechtzuerhalten, dass alle
Welten in der Situation des persönlich
im Determinismus lokalisierten, die
einer Entscheidung einer Person unterliegen,
möglich sind, aber nur eine von ihnen nach rationalem Gehirn
rational die für die Person am besten mögliche ist
Entscheidungsprinzipien sind
dann eine schwache Form allgemeiner und logischer Art
, die weder temporär noch
persönlich spezifiziert de sind  Terminismus könnte
gelten, wenn wir alle Prinzipien
,
die für das Geschehen relevant sind
, sowohl
als rational als auch als
nicht rational
betrachten  dies, selbst wenn Gott
die TC-Welt immer wieder auf den Zeitpunkt der
Entscheidung zurückfallen lässt, wie können wir dann einen
allgemeinen Determinismus im schwachen Sinne wie
oben angedeutet mit den beiden erforderlichen
Elementen vereinbaren, ob ein
Wort zu A oder B auf der einen  einerseits und in der
Lage zu sein, a zu tun und in der Lage zu sein, B zum
Zeitpunkt der Entscheidung zu tun, andererseits
könnten diese Elemente erfindungsgemß
nicht wahr sein, da das erste Element
eine persönliche Lokalisierung im
Determinismus impliziert und angesichts der Tatsache, dass eine persönliche
Lokalisierung im Determinismus unvereinbar ist
mit einem zweiten Element, das mit der
Fähigkeit verbunden ist, jeden der
unvereinbaren Klagegründe nach meinem Vorschlag durchzuführen, an dem wir festhalten können
das erste Element, dass genau ein
Klagegrund nur von einer rationalen
selbstbestimmten Entscheidung des Handelnden abhängt
und ihm daher
unter Bedingungen des persönlich
lokalisierten Determinismus a fortiori überlassen bleibt, nämlich der Klagegrund, der
aufgrund des ausgeübten
Conciliums am ehesten möglich ist  für den Handelnden
nach rationalen Prinzipien und
dies gilt, während die anderen
alternativen Handlungsursachen nicht nur
vom Handelnden abhängen, sondern von Faktoren
beeinflusst werden, die außerhalb seiner Kontrolle liegen
diejenige Wirkungsursache ausführen wird, die
der nach rationalen Prinzipien
möglichst möglichen möglichen Welt entspricht,
wenn
es nur an ihm liegt, ob er
die Handlung wählen wird, die
der nach rationalen Prinzipien möglichsten möglichen Welt entspricht
dann liegt
es auch nur an ihm, ob er
nicht die Handlung wählt, die
der möglichen Welt am ehesten entspricht
nach rationalen Grundsätzen
alles in allem
liegt es an ihm, ob er
die betreffende Handlung oder eine
Handlungsalternative in Bezug auf das
zweite erforderliche Element,
nämlich jede der Handlungsalternativen im entsprechenden Sinne ausführen zu
können, wählen wird
kein Grund zu der Annahme, dass es in einer Situation
des persönlich lokalisierten Determinismus
keine Fähigkeit im relevanten Sinne geben kann,
tatsächlich ist der einzige Grund für
eindringende Seiten zugunsten seiner Ansicht,
dass eine Person, die
über das Problem der Unbestimmtheit ausreichend informiert ist, keine
Entscheidung treffen könnte  sich vor seiner Entscheidung sicher sein
, wie er oder sie
entscheiden wird Tarun
argumentiert, dass eine solche Person vor einer
Entscheidung steht, zB vor der Entscheidung
, die
Übertretung eines Freundes in einer öffentlichen Konsultation zu verschweigen oder
nicht mit Sicherheit versprechen könne,
etwas zu tun  es sollte
jedoch inzwischen offensichtlich sein, dass, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass
die Bedingungen des persönlich
lokalisierten Determinismus zutreffen können  Anders als bei
der schwachen Form des Determinismus, den ich
beschrieben habe, nämlich dass eine dieser
alternativen Entscheidungen der nach rationalen Prinzipien
möglichst möglichen Welt entspricht,
könnte ich
also jetzt sicher sein, dass ich es tun werde, wenn ich mich an
die rationalen Prinzipien meiner Entscheidung
halte  tun, was in dieser Situation
nach vernünftigen Grundsätzen am besten möglich ist,
deshalb kann ich berechtigterweise
davon ausgehen, dass ich im entsprechenden
Sinne schweigen kann und
daher in der Lage bin, ein solches
Versprechen von vornherein vollkommen zu
vervielfältigen  in ein perfektes Duplikat
meiner jetzigen Situation versetzt würde zu 100%
immer die gleiche Entscheidung
nach den gleichen Prinzipien
treffen, wie auch immer die Entscheidung ausfallen mag, aber es gibt
keinen Grund, die Möglichkeit auszuschließen
, dass ein und dieselbe Person vor einer Entscheidung eine Entscheidung trifft
jede der Handlungsalternativen, zwischen
denen er sich zu entscheiden versucht,
schuldhaft ausführen kann